good afternoon everyone I welcome you to
this audit and rist meeting this
afternoon uh do we have any apologies
I
have I have one for Richard
mcf are there any other apologies I
think other
than that everyone is in attendance do I
have a mve for the that that apology
counselor Stringer seconded by counselor
guard I all all those in favor say I I
against
carried the first item on the agenda is
the health and safety report this is
written by people and culture M manager
Nikki Cooper Nikki would you like to
speak to this
report um predominantly through wish
through the chair we haven't got the
worship there today um overall I'll
pretty much consider R probably the only
area that probably like to just have
touch briefly on is the area of our
critical risk and also so the star boost
that we have in have showing that we're
showing Improvement I think the most
important thing for us to realize around
that is that we've got good levels of
structure happening over our journey but
it is not at the depth and the
consistency which I've put into the
report that we would like so it is a
journey and in terms of that um I guess
that vision of that we're moving forward
is one that I don't expect to move
particularly more until we really nail
down the things that we put in place
already so next time we see it I
wouldn't expect there to be an awful lot
of change until we embed a whole lot of
stuff but other than that I'm happy to
take questions between Lor and
I I open it up to the floor councelor
Stringer uh through you Mr cheer and
thank you noi
um the staff training um you've got
figur Z of who's been through the
um different trainings um do we have an
out of how many staff that is and um do
we know how many are overdue for
recertifications and and updates thank
you yep so in a our Total Staffing is
around sort of that 140 Mark but that's
made up of you know part-time plus
full-time employees so and of course
that that changes all the time um in
terms of training depends on the
department so three Waters will be a
heavily compliant training um area the
parks is a heavily cont compliant
training area where are some areas in
the business like um admin might bit of
first aid but in terms of actually being
compliant we're completely compant we've
got no outstanding training at all the
girls do a good job of reviewing that
pretty much on a weekly basis
prepopulate training ahead of times that
nobody laps us
yep
Michael chamber the in the report it
refers to that the key areas relate to
director and management which I assume
is Council and
management what's the strategy to get
the council and management up to speed
clearly they're lacking yeah okay so we
did actually have some um engagement
with the council terms of critical risk
so there some members of the council
attended that first training session so
had a better idea we're intending to
bring critical risk um botis and
overviews back to the council in
December so they have a better overview
and also stuff going into the long-term
plan to be able to support that we have
got in the background waiting to start
is a management walk uh program where
we're walking so site walks with um
[Music]
our counselors and our senior leaders
and each of the senior leaders have a
critical risk area that they're now
involved in and have to own so that's
more um for them and we also have our
consultant is starting to do um training
sessions which we think will probably
engage him in yeah as we move forward so
probably earlier in the year we'll start
more to focus in so it's an area of
definite Improvement for us
the followup question so my
understanding is this is this the
results are done by survey and therefore
part of the low rating for Council and
management will be the perception of
employees is that correct or not correct
no So within the back of the system
there is an a scale and I was going to
put a drawing of it in because I thought
this question might
come there's a number of questions that
are made up in that portion so the
management portion might have 10 or 15
independent questions relating to that
and in those that one question there's a
scale probably eight sort of scalable
where you can rate yourself against
where you believe you are and it has its
progressional so it might start off with
a very small amount as it works its way
through it gets more complicated and
more complicated and requires auditing
and lots of different um things like
that so that's based on the fact of us
sitting down with senior um myself Lori
and some other staff who are very
skilled in this area saying where do we
fit on the scale and self-rating
ourselves and that also then helps us to
know where it is we have to go to
improve Council Reed thank you Mr chair
um good report Nikki and really good to
see um a big improvement over those 12
months particularly around um the worker
and contractor engagement and emergency
preparedness um particularly the latter
given what we've been facing of recent
times um just good report thank you very
much keep up the good
work councilor
Stringer uh through you Mr ch um just on
page five looking at the graph on the
incident scheduled by type over the 5
month period um do we have any rundown
on the 26 near misses and the 66
injuries um how much time was lost over
this and um what is the severity of
those injuries like could have any of
them turned out to be fatalities or
anything like that anything
major okay good so let's start with the
26 misses so this is over that five
month period so over that 5 month period
probably the average was either six or
seven reports for the whole month so it
probably looks worse in its totality
than it is um and a lot of those things
are related to the pool and they're
across the business so there's not
really one area of the business that
isn't touched but predominantly we get a
lot of um and the MLT Center the N
misses those sort of things that we um
bleeding noses
um walking into things so the only one
that was um of concern was our own staff
member had a motorbike accident yeah so
that was probably the one of all of
those that could have been a little bit
serious
Nikki I have a couple of questions there
uh I see we're moving it uh strongly
into drug and alcohol
policy and uh coming from the mining
industry we used to have to blow the the
machine every every morning when you got
to work to make sure you're fit we we
haven't got people uh in most areas here
driving heavy machinery or working
machines that can kill people very
quickly uh do do we have bre do we have
a breath
and a a person trained to actually give
the do the
test no we don't have that sort of um
testing at this point in time it's not
in our policy it's not included in it um
no we prefer to leave to be honest that
kind of testing would be done by a
professional externally so if we had
that's why we have just cuse um in there
so if we felt that we needed to we would
get someone professional in who had the
calibrated gear who knew what they were
doing and who would keep to the um duty
of care of that sample so yeah a you
just get someone professional into make
sure we did if we needed
it with with a breathalizer test though
you you don't need to have them blow
into the machine that's calibrated is
it's not a a major to have one and CU if
you smell alcohol on someone or you've
got to do it then and there
so it's not something that I would put
any of our staff member in that position
where they would be taking um a
breathalizer test of someone that's why
we have the just cause if we smelt
alcohol then that would tick one of our
just CS boxes and so from there we would
then call in someone so that's in that
schedule of just calls where you would
TI off to say yes I smell alcohol and
reasonable call so therefore I have
calls to be able to reasonably call them
some someone they come pretty
quickly yeah my question you need them
within half an hour yeah okay thank
thank
you Mr just on the drug and alcohol
policy I've got a couple of questions
one is there's some evidence that when
organizations adopt drug policies
because marijuana stays in the system
for a long time and P doesn't uh they
discover that there's a shift of
marijuana use to peuse which in fact is
potentially more dangerous and is that
something that the council is uh
concerned about aware of or have
policies in place to
mitigate so that drug comes underneath
the testing that's already in the
schedule and the reason that this this
policy has a urine test and not a swab
is to help with that so swabbing often
disappears quicker um whereas by using
urine tests we have a better chance of
establishing whether we have meth or we
have marijuana and at what
level the other next question I had was
related to the process to adopt and
approve these sort of policies because
this is the first time it's come to the
orderin and risk committee and I would
have thought a policy of this nature
would come to the order and risk
committee prior to being
adopted
so in terms of this policy it's
operational it relates to the people
below I'm I'm unlikely to drug test well
you would never know if you were in the
building um it went through a formal
consultation process with the people so
a formal adoption reflection feedback
and then adoption and this was more in
terms of being able to show the audit
and risk committee that we had
implemented something that there was
something in place um so that you had
peace of mind around that because it's a
new policy to the
council through you Mr CH just to
supplement that answer this is a a
policy area that uh as chief executive
for a long time I was somewhat reluctant
to move into this territory but as we've
seen with the the prevalence of drug use
in mainstream Society uh and the nature
of the jobs we have some in some areas
of the
council I got we got to the conclusion
that we needed to have this policy
setting in place but as Nikki has
eloquently described it's a management
policy but from the order risk point of
view we need to know that we do have
something now in place and for those in
denial I mean you just look at the um
the waste water readings for uh puse
across the country and we're not
innocent in that regard to so all those
things I think militated or dictated
that we need to have some policy in
place but I didn't want to put something
out says to the staff well look you're
under suspicion it's just it's something
that we just want to make sure that we
can manage this risk given some jobs are
particularly dangerous if you're
infected with drugs or
[Music]
alcohol a minor question in the back of
the policy it says it was adopted on the
28th of August but in the report it says
the 18th of
September
could be a
typo was definitely not adopted till
after we'd finished the consultation
period so it was
in I'll make sure I fix
it Stringer uh three you Mr cheer um
just also in relation to the policy
there I see it now uh it uses the word
work workers um does that also cover
contractors as
well uh worker is a term that's used in
the health and safety and work act and
it does cover um any contractors um
employees visitors whatever it may be
but it's definitely a health and safety
term that we're trying to use more
rather than employees workers covers
everyone
yeah
to to add to that there's a standard
clause in council's contract to
contractors that says they must comply
with the council's health and safety and
other
policies has anyone got any other
comments
on
oh you Mr chair um interesting to see
that one of the um biggest challenges
that staff are feeling is the
interaction with um the members of the
community and I just wonder how we're
going you know like it's not just the
people here at the council at the front
desk getting it either it's it's people
that are out Contracting on the roadside
the gardeners so are they included in um
events that help them overcome that um
or encourage them to be able to deal
with those sorts of um behaviors when
they are
accosted yes the council um did a whole
lot of training probably five or six
months ago called situational training
um and a large proportion of the staff
went through with a particular focus on
Frontline those stuff that were public
facing um and that gave them a number of
skills how to deescalate or read a room
um we've just finished our well-being
day and part of that training was around
um thoughts and incoming messages from
other people and how you deal with it
emotionally and how you become mentally
resilient so that's something that all
just done last Wednesday um we have
support mechanisms in place should it
get really into you know there's help
for that and and also Lori has developed
a kind of like a refresher of how to
deal with situational training so that
when we have new staff coming in she's
able to gather a group of people
together and go through what they can do
based on what we already know we've sort
of made it a g District Council way of
how to deal with that but I'm in
complete agreement even talking today
with our
managers even the building control um
manager said people are angrier less
tolerant more aggressive and it's it
have is having an impact on our people
the pool um also the same way how do
those staff come so it's an ongoing
thing that I really need to be mindful
of and I need to consider even more ways
of supporting our staff I think it's a
very much a New Zealand thing all over
but certainly our staff are in the front
line we've also just started some um a
work group for down at the front office
so we're planning scenario planning
Sonia aren't we on actually identifying
what it might look like and how the
staff member might be able to respond
and then we're actually going to
practice like a fire drill running
scenarios for those
people so we're trying our best to
support you I think it's um very comfort
and to know that you've got it under
control well you're doing your best to
deal with it thank
you
MC
F you very much I I just like to
congratulate you I think this is a
really good start um there's lots of
things we can you can look at and think
can be slightly different but you've got
to start somewhere it's a good framework
you've got here the FR as far as the
front line stuff I take my head off to
them because believe me people coming
and uh taxes rates people get worked up
about things like that and it's handling
people on the front lines not easy
speaking from 30 years experience
um but well done good start
thanks anyone else got any other
comments they want to make on on the
report just finish if no one else wants
I'll just finish on a positive note if
you look on page 37 culture and
Leadership 88% of the workers survey
felt of the bo dist to council had effec
this governance and Leadership so I felt
re after reading all this I felt
reasonably good after
that in 78 felt that Senior Management
leaders create environment of fearness
and Trust so we have come a long way
so unless there's any other thing I'll
ask someone to move that that the the
report be
received councelor ofal are you moving
that way yeah seconded councelor Reed
all those in favor to say I
against carried we'll now move on to I
want to find my
page LMA requests for July to September
Sonia would you like to speak on
that uh thank you through the chair um
I'll just take the repor has WR and
happy to answer any questions um it's
really obvious that we've seen quite a
remark will decline in the number of L
requests and the complexity of them so
which is a good
thing councilor strer three Mr chair um
are we still sitting slightly higher
than where we should be like compared to
the start of the year are we or is this
about normal for requests coming through
now at this stage we're about on par
with previous years um we'll see where
we go from here
[Music]
when the solicitor asks us do we get to
know who's actually asking the
question uh yes we do yes they they do
name their um who they're acting on
behal
of councilor
Stringer Mr chair um I know it's been
previously said at um previous audit on
risks where we've had such a high number
of um Bea requests that we were looking
at doing a
charge out after so many hours did we
ever Implement that or get into that
that
territory uh through the chair no we
managed to actually process all the
requests and the required time with um
and not with too many hours um there are
there is one currently that we have
advised that we will be charging for
which has been accepted by the
aquesta any other questions or comment
on the
report could I have move the
report uh all those in favor say I
I against
carried now we've got the three Waters
uh service
report is Aaron not here okay you going
to speak uh through you Mr chair um Mr
Green has asked that I uh present the
report on behalf of him um he said to
take the report as read and if there's
any questions we can feed them back to
him and he'll respond to the elected
members does anyone have any questions
about the
report I suspect that the major flooding
event caused the delay uh in the well is
the flooding
event 88 minutes so
other than that we seem to be within our
guidelines with each of the
items through you Mr I think it's a it's
a good report and a good discipline to
be capturing this
information
Stringer uh through you Mr Cher um sort
of in relation to this report but um are
there any other services that we we run
crms and time required um completion
that we should be getting reports on
such as
roading uh through you Mr chair we do
collect the information but we don't we
haven't done any Haven been asked for
any formal reports the information is
available to be to be reported on if
it's something that elected members want
as part of the kpis is it's a LEL a
longterm plan discussion and could be
one of the things that elected members
suggested that
time
Mr Perry yes uh through you Mr chairman
just further to that there is
information in the infrastructure
bulletin that comes out uh which
includes a lot of the um you know
response times uh and the CRM type level
so it's a matter of whether orderin R
committee want that type of information
into this particular environment but it
is actually available and post on our
website thank you is there any other
comments on this report
could I have a mve that the report be
received Mr Chamberlain seconded by
councel
Gardine all those in favor please say I
I against
carried they we'll move on to the RIS
pool scheme report general manager of
corporate services you like to comment
uh thank you Mr chair um and through you
the council have received a letter
advising us of um an
outstanding uh CLA potential claim
there's um three risk pole the council
was a member of risk pole back in the
day and had um removed ourselves from
the poll in 2017 I believe it was
however any of the activity that happens
up until that point we are still liable
for so there's been when we're waiting
for a court case to go through um go
through the system and to see what the
outcome of that was the court has
um has gone in favor of um not of
riskful of the of the um move the right
way arounds a bit client yes and um and
so what we what we don't know at the
moment is the Quantum of the value of of
the um call that may be made on the
council so the basically there's another
high court hearing and December that
will um talk to costs costs of that CL
and whether we will be required to to be
um liable for any funds um you know the
report the report is fairly Fair
standard we'll take it as read but it's
also been included in their annual
report as a as a note to our readers to
make them aware that that it is
there councilor
gon does it have any um evidence of the
complainant or is it is it another
Council trying to claim on the risk pool
is it or is it an individual
so it was an individual um against a
council and the council or the council's
been has I think it's napia Council that
it was um it I'm pretty sure it says it
in the letter
somewhere no it doesn't it's in another
piece um yeah it's on mother Council who
it basically goes to whether it's
weathertight or non-weather tight and
the case was around whether the
non-weather tight event would or costs
would be included and the court has
ruled that the non-weather tight event
uh cost will be included as well rather
than just the Wither tight
costs
so how big is the the guess no one's
guess at at this stage they there's no
idea of the Quantum of it um we will be
no more later in the
year I think Mr chairman the uh the sent
question is how many properties involved
if it's just a singular property it's
it's probably
manageable we have had other cases where
I don't think the the council
participating was a RIS pool member but
um you we there's multiple leaky homes
that have to be settled and that's where
it gets into the upper echelons of um
affordability other questions or
comments on this
report is there a risk to us or to
council's
insurers uh through you Mr chair risk
pool was our insurer at the time we were
part of that poll um
so if they'll have some funds available
to them but what the difference is will
be what was spread amongst the councils
that were part of it at the
time Council
Stringer uh through you Mr chair are
there any other insurance polls like
this that the council's partaken and
that could
um or might have um caught things
pending that could come back and and Ru
favor of the
plaintiff um three Mr here not in sense
of the plaintiff we are part of the lap
scheme for underground infrastructure so
that as a pool of um various councils
across the country and what they do is
they try and spread the the group of
councils across the country to minimize
the impact of any one event affecting
multiple councils so that that is one
one other joint scheme there are
benefits to some of those joint schemes
as well and that you can get better
premiums you can have bigger portfolio
to take to the market to get insurance
for so there is a calculated balance and
risk associated with these but um there
is argument because New Zealand's such a
small Market to pulling that is a good
idea but again it's that that
risk
Shan do do we understand the basis that
the ultimate amount is going to be split
between councils or is that something
that's still subject to negotiation as
well three Mr chair it was based it's
based on shareholding and I don't have
that information to hand at the moment
but we could um go back to our archive
from 2017 and and find that
out any other questions or comment on
this
report if not I ask that someone please
move
the all those in favor please say I I
against
carried sorry the final part of this
meeting is the age dat's report to the
30th of September I ask you know man
soor our management accountant to
comment on that sorry I should have
introduced on the front here sorry
Michael to to the welcome Michael thank
you through you Mr chair I'll take this
I'll take this report as read and I'm
happy to take any questions from you or
the rest of the
committee
one question here I see that the
outstanding rates of the 30th of
September up to
$643,000
now that in that September quarter we
had build about $6.4 Million worth of
rat so we've got is that quite a high
default coming in
now so the way I understand it is it's
actually a timing issue so by the time
um 30 June next year it will come back
down to the 1.2 to 1.5 it's just the way
it sort of sits in the system I think
that's how it works or now might have a
different three Mr CH yeah there is a
timing difference in and when when um
rate payers pay their rates but um as a
general observation we are we are seeing
more defaults we are seeing more um
insufficient funds come through the bank
statement and and paying um the team are
really proactive in trying to set up um
payment schemes for the work for the
rate payers and work with them um you
know last res for us is sending them to
debt collection or um doing the mortgage
sales that is absolutely last result we
try and work with them as much as we can
ahead of time to pay start paying
something
off
the I hate to keep beating my hobby
horse but I'm assuming that we are still
actively promoting the rates um rebate
scheme uh through you Mr chair yes we've
got a very proactive um customer support
team and um they are very very good when
people come in to say have you heard of
this are you aware of it it's not just
for um our older generation it's also
for younger people who are maybe single
income um maybe struggling um but we do
have one of our customer support par
people who is very proactive and goes
out into the community as well to people
in their homes helps them helps them
fill it in and it so we do try and push
that as far as much as we
can to hear thank you
Council so if I look at at the um um bit
at the bottom of page 49 that talks
about 237,000 with 38 rate payers works
out at
6,250 on average each so I'm picking
there's some feel really large ones in
there um what sort of profile are we
looking at in terms of the range of
people or
businesses through you Mr chair look
there's some of these are built up over
a number of years uh there was one or
two years where they um the rates or the
outstanding debts were not afforded to
debt management for collection so that
could be a couple years worth of rates
or two or three years worth of rates
that haven't been paid and that's why
the average is so high so on the whole
it is tends to be mult couple years
worth that um that have been caught
there just looking at the resource
consents and building consense um the
rate of um slowness of payment I thought
that was reasonably simple you didn't
get your consent till you pay the
money or the head of the um dat work
there is it people just holding up on
that is the consent h back until the
money's paid or they they
granted I can I can help with regard to
Resource consent you cannot legally
withhold a consent um for the final
payment um but there is an opportunity
when it's progress payments through the
processing of the consent to hold it up
until appropriate monies are paid uh we
have a deposit scheme and once the
deposits paid I think we have a legal
obligation to follow it through all the
way so so it's a matter then of making
sure that the deposit is actually a
reasonable um share of of the total
likely
Bill and through Mr chairman I think
with building consense is that um there
may well be um fees payable as the
building consent is processed and
sometimes they can take quite a long
time because if there's further
information required so the invoice is
raised they they're working through the
consent process and it could be
sometimes um two or three months before
the the consent pops out of his further
information is placed on hold but the
invoice is in the system and then what
happens is once it's issu before it's
actually issued we ask for payment so
that's probably why the these amounts
are in the
system thank you for that
explanation
councelor heral and
second Michael
Chamberlain all those in
favor I say I against
carried that brings us to the conclusion
of the O open meeting we'll now move
into public excluded